out of this story the FDA is taking what
it calls historic first steps to make
new rules to reduce nicotine and
cigarettes to make them less addictive
the government estimates about five
million people would quit smoking within
a year for the new nicotine limits
taking effect the FDA believes the
changes could drastically decrease
smoking rates among American adults from
15 percent to 1.4 percent tobacco use
kills almost half a million Americans
every year dr. David agus leads USC's
westside Cancer Center good morning all
right smoking is at an all-time low but
this could make that even better yeah it
makes an all-time low but we're still
are smoking way too much you know
nicotine is interesting it's a natural
compound plants make it so when bugs eat
them it actually kills the bugs and so
we take that as a stimulant and it's
addictive so the more nicotine and
there's actually been more nicotine and
tobacco over the last several decades it
makes it more addictive and this bold
plan is let's change it to the other
direction and reduce nicotine so it's
less addictive does the nicotine cause
the cancer we think it's the tar and the
other impurity that causes the cancer
but the nicotine causes the addiction
which keeps you to smoke so it becomes
this circle so if somebody's addicted
wouldn't they just smoke a lot more
cigarettes you would think so but in the
trial that was done several years ago
and published in New England Journal of
Medicine is when you reduce nicotine you
actually reduce smoking and especially
the teenagers the new smokers coming on
lower nicotine they're gonna smoke less
so we have to watch out for that but
there really is a plan here hopefully
the ROO smoking in this country this is
essentially weaning people is that
basically it well it's not clear and
they're actually the FDA has asked for a
data on weaning versus a cold turkey
going down dramatically on the number of
nicotine you know we say smoking is in
all-time low but still four hundred and
eighty thousand deaths a year attributed
this is the only consumer product when
used as directed will kill half of the
long-term users the tobacco you're
talking Sabac oh yes so the tobacco
companies who reached out to some of
them they say they will work with the
FDA while it formulates the nicotine
limit limits so do you think reducing
the nicotine limits you're a cancer
doctor is gonna make a big difference
damn straight I mean you reduce nicotine
you reduce the dependence this is an
addictive drug so people smoke less
there will be less lung cancer and less
heart disease how much do they have to
reduce it David so I don't have a name
we don't know but we think it's going to
be pretty dramatic 75 80 90% reduction
in the nicotine in tobacco is vaping
safer we don't know I mean the jury's
still out
they've been as a delivery route for
nicotine so it's still getting nicotine
in the lungs but you need a carrier
molecule so the safety of vaping is
still under investigation
thank you thank you dr. David egg it's
always good to see you thank you guys
great to see you